family you have no kids you know 32.  i got i got three kids i'm 31 so i you  know i took a little different route  now man but you you have no kids why do  you want kids ultimately do you not want  kids i mean that's a that's a big  commitment  for one and i always felt like i was  just really zoned in on my work in my  alone time and my free time  too much for me to like lock in or  something like that you know and  eventually i do want that but the older  i get i think is the better because i'm  maturing more ignoring myself more  understanding my situation a little bit  more so if i were to invite someone in  or combine my life with another person  you know it'd be perfectly perfect at  this time as opposed to me 10 years ago  i wouldn't know what to do so  i think i'm as long as i wait you know  it's only going to be for the better